assalaamu alaikum greetings of peace i'm
with the president and founder of sound
vision
how are you well i'm doing just fine and
i hope you all are doing a great and
enjoying ramadan
look we wanted to get your input there
was a really
horrific piece that's
going viral it's out there it says isis
which obviously the daesh you know these
people who are obviously killing muslims
many people don't know this
we you know we condemn this group we
don't like this group
um that they actually beheaded a
four-year-old girl get this a
four-year-old girl
made her mom because she told her mother
that or the the story goes something
like this that the
the mother told the child if you don't
come inside the house i'm gonna behead
you
and then the child and i swear by god so
then someone
from the isis heard this went back
and told the the court the police they
came
and because she didn't fulfill her vow
they allegedly ended up
killing beheading a four-year-old girl
disgusting barbec crazy but then you
start to put these pieces together you
see it's an unconfirmed source
uh what kind of mother would tell her
child i'm gonna behead you
i mean people what do you what are your
comments on this on this
this crazy story well you know
all muslims understand isis is
radical isis is extremist isis is
terrorist entity
it's a creation of war which is
unjustified itself so since it's their
evil
islamophobes are using media in a
marvelous way
islamophobia is a 200 million machine
and they're placing fake stories and
also to build
on already which is horrible situation
so
and and this might be one why there is a
news report
but while it is not unconfirmed it is so
horrible that all of us will be repelled
by it
but if it is so horrible how come nobody
bothered to confirm that
it's a rumor who started that rumor i
mean there is a shia sunni thing going
on
so some references which i read go back
to iran
are they creating some fake news or
islamophobes in america
are enjoying having a field day creating
isis is horrible all muslims are against
that
but but is everything is authentic for
example saddam hussein
was a horrible person but we were told
that they are throwing babies in the
incubators
forward again to august 2nd 1990
iraq attacks kuwait claiming the
kuwaitis are slant drilling
into iraq's oil fields u.s president
george herbert walker bush
pushes for a land war against iraq but
polls show the u.s public is split
50 50 on that idea then comes
this eyewitness testimony before a
congressional committee
from a 15-year-old kuwaiti girl the
claim is
she cannot be identified for fear of
reprisals
while i was there i saw the iraqi
soldiers coming to the hospital with
guns
they took the babies out of the
incubators
took the incubators and left the
children to die on a cold floor
the u.s public is outraged the result
support for land war zooms it's a
turning point
desert storm is launched
135 000 iraqis are killed
an estimated 1 million iraqis many of
them children and old people
then die as a result of 10 years of
sanctions
one small problem there never were
any incubator baby deaths not one
the canadian broadcasting corporation's
investigative
flagship program the fifth estate
reveals the girl to
be the kuwaiti ambassador's daughter
given her lines and coached in acting by
the giant american pr firm
hill and knowlton it's one phase in a 10
million dollar
joint u.s kuwaiti campaign of deception
this man is lying i myself
buried 14 newborn babies
that had been taken from their
incubators this man is lying
they had kids and incubators and they
were thrown out of the incubators
so the kuwait could be systematically
dismantled there were a lot of people
who participated in a conspiracy
yes an out and out conspiracy of fake
organizations
false documents fraud and disinformation
and later on it would find out that the
pr firm in
washington dc was using the daughter
of the kuwaiti ambassador to
say all those things which she did not
see because she was safely in america
so so based on that horror story
all sort of nonsense is possible so it
is extremely important
that we remain focused uh
on when you see something
you need to question call the media call
the reporter
and ask all the right question that
if their source is not clear why they
are not waiting to confirm the source
so muslim remain horrified by all both
the terrorists on one side on
islamophobes
on the other side so this is this is
actually a command from the creator
allah who tells in the quran to check it
up to verify
these things don't we have a command in
the quran talking about this
well quran directly in surah raj said
that when you have a person of
unreliable service coming with the news
verify that information so it is in
surat al-hajrad
so you need to verify that information
having said that you know
isis is a problem isis is terrorism
and that's what some people what
unreliable sources keep attributing
everything
so islam folks taking islam advantage
of terrorism and terrorism taking
advantage of islamophobia
and out at the third element war war
terror and hate all three have element
of lies in there so muslim need to be
careful and watch out
so when you see something say something
when you say wrong news
you need to speak up when you see a
muslim doing wrong
say something right can we ending on
that note
you got to be radically insane i usually
recommend this book it's called a
complete idiot's guide to understanding
islam by yahweh emmerich because you got
to be a complete
idiot if you're going to somehow connect
these radical crazy extreme things
to islam can we can we agree on that
well yes
some wise people need to read books
written for idiots
thank you shane we'll see you peace be
with you